all right so we're going to begin this
hour with our new series we're going to
begin this hour with me isn't that what
you wanted to say I didn't want to say
that yeah but I know I'm just here in
this playground for it's temporary uh
we're beginning with our new series
never too late that is where Gail Tony
Nate and I try to show that it's never
too late to learn something new so I
have always been fascinated by the
history of the samurai sword and how
Japanese swordsmanship has evolved into
a martial art today so in order to tread
in the path of a seminite one must first
understand the concept of Bushido the
path or way of the Warrior by mastering
several disciplines like tamashigiri and
Kendo I decided to spend some time
learning about the sword and visited a
dojo to understand what it takes to
truly Master the sword it isn't easy but
the Japanese have a saying fall down
seven times stand up
[Music]
for decades the Samurai warrior wielding
his long sword called the katana has
been mythologized and Pat was films both
in Japan and in Hollywood
it has a sharp and Rich history one that
I always wanted to explore nice but
before I could take the first step in
mastering the art
there you go I had to learn all about it
the craftsmanship like this one is
beautiful look at that so I took a trip
to New York City's Metropolitan Museum
of Art
to check out the samurai Splendor
exhibition with art curator Marcus cesco
give us a sense of the life of a typical
Samurai in Japan in the 17th and 18th
century the Tokugawa the rulers of the
country that introduced like a class
system no one but the samurai were
allowed to wear swords he saw the sword
as a symbol of his ruling of of his role
in the society
but that symbol fell out of favor in
1850 when the United States forced Japan
to open itself up to trade with the west
and the country began to industrialize
the only reason a warrior is alive to
fight and the only reason a warrior
fights is to win otherwise why be a
warrior it was thought of
the battlefield Readiness had to be kept
alive and it has to be passed on to a
successive Generations
like Sensei noburu kataroka a master of
the way of the sword of more than 30
years who's appeared in films like Clint
Eastwood's letters from Iwo Jima
and Black Rain starring Michael Douglas
Sensei kataoka's martial art is called
Kendo
you have to have a technique the certain
way to move very delicate techniques
like a piano if you don't have any
techniques and make music make sound but
it's not beautiful
you can only fight the way you practice
Kendo is now practiced more as a sport
than a martial art on the battlefield
you target specific places on the body
to score points
but the real goal is to achieve a level
of skill where the techniques come as
second nature
how hard is it to get to that level of
it becoming just like breathing you have
to do same thing over and over like a
meditation
and then eventually you'll get it
one thousand days of lessons for
discipline Ten Thousand Days of lessons
for Mastery
it was time to armor up
and turn those words into action you'll
go back and up soon and here comes the
dog
[Music]
very good
[Applause]
doubt
so okay that's very good
and the confusion those things comes in
then you lose
oh very good
yeah
thank you very much and you lose the
focus you lost
Beyond Kingdom which historically
sharpened the samurai skill against an
opponent with bamboo swords
there's tamashigiri
art of cutting with a live blade
Sensei sang Kim teaches classes in New
York City I'm very excited to learn what
do you have in mind for me so today
we're going to just teach you some of
the basics about the cutting and then
hey we might actually give it a try and
let you try test cutting all right just
let you know I'll let you close my sword
my swords are kind of expensive if you
break you bye
make sure our executive producer has her
checkbook ready
turn to give it a go first things first
you're going to step forward with your
right foot and put your left hand on
your sword first by learning the proper
form pop pop then and then perfect good
pull your left hand back as you push
your right hand forward
good and bring it up
now have your left hand meet
Perfect all right so this time from
there very nice we're gonna do our first
cut we want to go straight down and the
biggest thing is relax don't over swing
okay let's give it a try and go
nice you hear that sound yeah
so if you hear hasuji that means your
blade alignment is correct finally time
to put practice to the test deep breath
and relax
ready and cut
oh okay one more time uh don't bend
forward okay ready and cut
oh okay one more time
take your time deep breath cut
okay
it is said the Journey of a Thousand
Miles
begins with the first step
and it's never too late to start
it's usually beautiful Tony decopo we've
been waiting for you why don't you go
first Tony oh thank you guys I miss you
hope to see you next week things are
going well here I'm Vlad I'm very
impressed but I have a key question for
you I know you want to keep doing the
samurai thing I see some swords on Ebay
I could send you one but are you really
confident that Marion's gonna let you
have a samurai sword in the house with a
toddler uh Tony look what Gail is
holding uh and her answer is no the
answer is we've got a lot of swords in
the house yeah so these are actually
your swords these are my swords the ones
that uh we have here on set Gail is
holding what is called a what's
wakazashi uh it's a short sword okay and
you are holding the Chennai which is the
bamboo sword that we used to do Kendo
but Tony what did we think of lad's
technique number one it's visually
beautiful thank you let me shout out
first let me give a shout out to Alyssa
candiotti and veto ice Blum who produced
uh Craig Shea who was the editor and
Iana Velez who did those beautiful
Graphics I mean I went back to her so
many times for those graphics and they
knew
it makes me a little nervous to be
honest with you just holding I've seen
you cut potatoes I'm not putting it
right yeah now you're putting it
backwards here
this is how Gail is
you learned so you have to teach your
daughter
I learned something about you know and
you you heard what Sensei katooka said
about fear and doubt uh and anger
creeping into your mind confusion the
Japanese and the Chinese too have a word
for it it's called mushin mushin in
Chinese mushin means no mind so if you
can experience no mind while you're
practicing anything in life not just
this anything that you do in life if you
have no mind about it that will lead you
on the path I'm repeating that to my
kids later I like lose focus you lose
you lose focus you keep that thank you
Vlad thank you this was a fun series
Tony thank you we look forward can't
wait to have you back Tony next week yes
yes see you guys next week all right all
right